welcome back to las vegas now
intermountain healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment is the official
healthcare partner of our raiders so
both organizations have come together to
help the community and make some dreams
come true and this time they're giving
kids survivors a chance to be kid
reporters check it out coming to you
live from the intermountain health care
performance center is raiders kid
reporter mckenna kearns what is your
favorite food when you aren't playing
football what would you do cats or dogs
dogs
winter or summer
summer and at just six and a half years
old kid reporting is not her only area
of expertise
tap
ballet
cheerleading and i love makeup her most
successful feat yet though
being a cancer survivor so mckenna was
five and a half months old when she was
diagnosed with retinoblastoma
the tumor was so far advanced that
we needed to remove her eye
sorry
she's done
incredible
and nothing has stopped her
even
she does gymnastics and bounces across
the beam she skis downhill she
does everything that
any other kid does to this point
so she's been
incredible she's a champ and kendra
morris with intermountain healthcare
says in this case a champ means more
than just a champion so the kid reporter
segment really speaks to our current
intermountain and raiders campaign and
that's called
the champ
campaign so like we are telling people
to discover their inner champ and champ
actually means community
health activity
mental well-being and purpose not only
was mckenna able to interview her
favorite raiders player aj cole who she
thinks is very funny by the way do you
have any jokes what is beethoven's
favorite fruit
she received vip access to the team's
official headquarters and practice field
i did
cartwheels
and
i got to throw the ball
now this experience with intermountain
healthcare and the raiders has prepared
mckenna for success whether it's for
being a future raiderette generators
a reporter what scares you
what scares me hmm i have a well i just
said i like hiking but i have a little
bit of a fear of hikes so i like hiking
but not getting too close to the edge a
better game day buddy for her dad i used
to think
the raiders game
writers games were boring but
now
they're fun
and an inspiration to her peers it's
okay to be different from other kids you
can still do it and i believe in you
my girl mckenna we're rooting for you
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment head to
raiders.com
champ for more information